[Music]
let me come back to one that you
mentioned and that is kava so
a friend of mine reached out to me
recently to get my two cents on a new a
new supplement that he is taking in
place of his evening cocktail
so he's decided he's in his 70s and has
decided to cut back on alcohol intake
because he sees how alcohol affects his
sleep using an aura ring and other
devices
and he switched to this supplement which
contains two things kratom
and kava
and i know very little about kaaba
kratom i have some thoughts on i'll be
curious to hear your thoughts on uh
contains mature gianine seems to hit
opiate receptors so i i believe there
are people who
abuse kratom who have now developed
dependencies that are in rehab at least
i've heard some stories related to that
but i know far less about cava
would you mind elaborating
on
cava sure
cava is the major
uh psychoactive plant that's used in
oceania in many islands throughout the
pacific it's the
very large root of a large plant in the
black pepper family
and it is
has unique chemistry in many of these
islands people make a beverage from it
originally by chewing the root and
spitting it into a bowl and mixing it
with water or coconut juice or now more
often drying it and powdering it and
mixing it into a liquid and it is
functions as a social stimulant and
lubricant but it is a natural sedative
and cognitive and probably the most
important anti-anxiety
natural product out there extremely
useful and and essentially no toxicity
and so
it does not interact with alcohol it
does not interact with other sedatives
it's quite safe and i recommend it very
frequently to people
do you know what effect if any it has on
sleep quality
my friend has the subjective experience
of it helping him to wind down and go to
sleep but i wonder
what effect it has on sleep quality
because you look at some say sleep aids
like ambien and so on which help you to
fall asleep but they affect
the cycles of sleep and depth that's
putting it mildly you know all of these
all of these sleep understatements yeah
whether over-the-counter or prescribed i
think are dangerous drugs first of all
they don't reproduce natural sleep all
of them suppress dreaming which is an
essential component of good sleep
they distort sleep architecture they're
addictive and they interfere with
cognitive function so i i think there's
really no justification for using them
unless
for very short-term use because of
situational insomnia but kava has none
of these ill effects it can be used
long-term regularly i don't know that we
have good studies on how it affects
sleep quality but i don't know of any
indications that it has any of those
adverse effects that the
usual sleep aids do and i suppose i
should actually just go back to my
friend who is
granted tracking imperfectly but he's
tracking his sleep with the aura ring
that does capture some biometric data
that is sort of
interpolated to
land on percentage of sleep as different
phases including rem and so on so i i
should actually just go back to him but
the problem tim is that he's using
kratom also which is a significant agent
and
we really would like to see this with
cava alone what it does could you expand
on that please
well i i don't know that much about
kratom it's been used in
indonesia where it's native to help
people break opiate opioid dependence
and it it has sedative effects and
opioid-like effects i think there is a
downside to it
and some concern about people using it
in not good ways but i'm not an expert
on kratton
you